r
sur la scène municipale.
- En marchant dans
les rues de Côte-des-Neiges-
Notre-Dame-de-Grâce,
Gracia Kasoki Katahwa,
infirmière de 35 ans,
apprivoise peu à peu
son nouveau statut de mairesse.
venez du Congo,
vous, on m'a dit?
- Oui! Vous connaissez?
t bien! De quel Congo?
- Congo Kinshasa.
Parce que Monsieur me disait :
"Ah, c'est vous! Parce que
je pensais que c'était M. Perez,
c'est moi qui ai gagné, oui!
- Il aura fallu un recomptage
pour que soit confirmée
sa victoire contre Lionel Perez,
un pilier de la politique
municipale.
GRACIA KASOKI KATAHWA,
mairesse CDN-NDG
- Les gens ont choisi la vision
de Projet Montréal, donc d'une
métropole à échelle humaine.
Je pense que oui, les gens
ont choisi mon profil,
comme j'ai dit, une infirmière,
quelqu'un à qui on peut faire
confiance. Je suis une citoyenne
qui est engagée depuis longtemps
puis je pense que ça,
c'est un élément qui a fait
la différence. Est-ce que mon
origine a fait la différence?
Je pense qu'il y a plusieurs
personnes ici qui se disaient :
"Bien, il est temps, en fait,
là, qu'on ait une mairesse
d'arrondissement qui est aussi
issue de la diversité."
- Félicitations!
(rires)
- Grac arrive
au Québec en 1989,
à l'âge de 3 ans.
Ses parents s'installent
à Québec, où elle passe
sa jeunesse et fait
toutes ses études.
Mais en 2009, elle choisit
d'amorcer sa carrière
d'infirmière à l'Hôpital
général juif de Montréal.
la réflexion,
puis je me suis dit :
moi, j'ai envie de vivre...
j'ai envie d'expérimenter,
finalement, une société qui est
plus dis c'est pour ça
que j'ai choisi spécifiquement
Côte-des-Neiges... Côte-des-
Neiges-Notre-Dame-de-Grâce
et l'Hôpital juif pour ça,
parce là, j'étais
un peu tannée d'être toujours
la seule Noire quelque part,
t'sais, j'ai fait toutes
mes études comme ça.
vole engagée, membre
du plusieurs C.A. et maintenant
gestionnaire en santé,
elle côtoie les résidents de
Côte-des-Neiges depuis 12 ans :
une population qui parle
plus de 80 langues.
- Clairement, Montréal
doit rester une métropole
francophone en Amérique du Nord.
La population immigrante...
comment dire, en a vu d'autres.
C'est vraiment, comme j'ai dit,
un peu... lors de ma première
conférence de presse, c'est
un parcours du c
donc tout ce qu'on peut faire
pour s'assurer de s'intégrer,
on va le faire.
Vous êtes les premiers
que je rencontre
- Alors, doublement... honoré!
(rires)
JEAN ISSERI, dg, Carrefour
Jeunesse-Emploi de CDN
- C'esnnement.
C'est un couronnement
d'avoir une mairesse issue
de la communauté noire.
Bravo! On est honorés de...
n.
KARIM OUERTANI,
propriétaire, Caravane Café
- On a besoin de changement.
Et je pense que je le perçois
vement et on va essayer
de travailler avec la nouvelle
mairesse pour pouvoir donner
du mieux du quartier.
- Sa priorité pour
l'arrondissement : acheter
des terrains ou des immeubles
pour augmenter le nombre
de logements abordables.
- Je le sais qu'il y a
beaucoup d'attentes puis
il y a beaucoup de besoins.
Je suis contente qu'on puisse
commencer à travailler...
J'ai une première rencontre avec
le caucus de Projet Montréal de
Côte-des-Neiges-NDG aujourd'hui.
- Une rencontre qui, ce jour-là,
a lieu à l'hôtel de ville
de Montréal, qu'elle visite
seulement pour la deuxième fois.
- C'est toujours aussi
impressionnant, toujours aussi
impressionnant. C'est vraiment
un privilège d'être ici.
(cris de joie)
(applaudissements)
- Diriger, elle le sait,
signifie parfois prendre
des décisions difficiles,
mais elle promet de
demeurer l'infirmière
derrière chez la mairesse.
- Même si je suis capable
de dire à certaines personnes
parfois : bien, malheureusement,
on n'ira pas dans la direction
que tu m'as proposée,
bien, je le fais avec
bienveillance quand même.
- Sur la scène municipale,
Gracia Katahwa se fait
déjà remarquer.
MAGDA POPEANU, conseillère
district CDN, Projet Montréal
- C'est ne femme de tête et de
coeur, une femme organisée, mais
en même temps, qui a le coeur
à la population, à l'écoute.
On a beaucoup discuter
comment je peux mettre
en pratique tout ce que
j'ai entendu.
- C'est de l'excitation,
c'est un peu... Moi, j'ai
fait du théâtre dans ma vie,
donc c'est un peu comme juste
avant de rentrer sur scène,
tu utilises toute cette énergie-
là pour t'assurer de bien
performer, que ce soit de
l'énergie positive, donc c'est
un peu comme ça que je me sens.
- Au revoir!
- Merci, au revoir!
- Prête à jouer le rôle
principal dans l'arrondissement
le plus peuplé de Montréal.
Ici Jean-Sébastien Cloutier,
Radio-Canada, M